[Music]
there's no assigned seating first come
first serve
i'm gonna sit in the middle
i better sit next to you the sparkling
sake is delicious so this is my take on
a butter crab roll this has a yuzu and
truffle aioli mixture as well as crispy
shallots on top of some texture
you're in spectacular honestly nikki
seriously what a treat
grab balls i'll have a crab a ball like
is it the balls of the crab yeah taste
it
they only make them in cuba let's try it
it's cuban sushi but it's not the balls
wait hold on here
i have to ask you guys a very personal
question okay have you guys ever heard
of men putting pearls in the shaft
[Applause]
no i heard about
you never heard of other pearls in the
ass no we've heard like different
volcanoes lisa it's a penile implant for
pleasure for the ladies and it's very
common in cuba you guys i've never used
a sex toy in my life
yeah i've never used a sex toy before i
don't know if i believe her
i don't want to say what i have used but
it's not a sex toy
americans might think that like a [ __ ]
ring
is pretty kinky but i feel like the
cubans upped it and took it to a
different level by the way did you
realize you and lisa are twinning
julia i have to ask you this
if you come out and are a lesbian yes
does that mean you will never be with
another man again i'm just asking i
don't i am bisexual i will leave who do
i like more
i don't know it's love love has no
agenda you know happened to meet martina
i love her i'm faithful to her do i look
at other people god absolutely yes
it's perfect that you're talking about
this because i'm actually receiving an
award on saturday night for being
bisexual
i've been a long time ally of the lgbtq
and most of you don't even know why
after my father died i found out that he
was gay
oh my god
your father
my father
told me that never told anybody it's the
first time in 31 years
that i have actually said this
my mother i understand now and i kind of
like forgive her because she was
protecting me like she didn't want me to
have like that
vision of my dad which he thought was
like a bad thing but it was actually a
good thing my dad was like the best dad
in the world all this information about
alexia's father being gay this is like a
bomb but that's alexia's life it's
always like one crazy
story after another
but alexa you know what they say we
always repeat a pattern of our parents
20 years later i married a guy man
i married somebody like my dad and then
my dad and herman took that secret to
the grave oh wow
back then with the cuban culture it was
not okay to be gay i can't even imagine
like
the agony you know that my father had to
live with
because he was never able to come out of
the closet it was like a double life
like what herman had 30 years later the
man that i married and the man that i
buried were two different people i even
found out that gentleman was there at
the funeral you know he was what
gentleman germans love her
you never knew that with herman he
always denied it you know what i think
it's like a soulmate thing so i think he
fell in love with me for like who i was
but then other factors came into play
like at his funeral
somebody told me that he died while
having sex with a man
well you know what if that's the case
that's the way i want to die too
oh my god
[Music]
you